So let's imagine that it is in fact possible
for you to run faster than the speed of light
and so doing travel back in time still would
be wildly responsible I knew you're going to
say this yes because very you were to go into the
past any interaction you have with your parents
or yourself you step on the wrong blade of grass
you have no idea what the consequences to that
can be no I know the butterfly effect right yes
I get it the Bruce I can fix things I could save
my mom save your parents you could also destroy
everything there is no much a tragedy to find you
hey Mom you want to get nuts let's get nuts when
you go back and change the
past you change the future
we're fine I'm fine I'm in so much trouble
you're the reasons about the destroy the
Earth maybe want some help yeah I'm Batman wait
he's Batman what did you think we were doing here
I will help you fight tonight you can
go anywhere got another time why do
you always like to save this one
this is the one where my mom lives
Barry what are you doing our
kids are gonna want to see this
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie there's a brand
new Flash trailer with a bunch more Batman so
we'll break it all down also explain Flashpoint
Batman 2 because they've obviously changed some
things from the comics but there's a lot of
references to the original Flashpoint Comics
too during that story they do a lot of really
interesting things with the Mythos because of the
alternate timeline flash creates always creating
amazing things by messing up the timeline both on
the Flash TV show and during The Flash movie now
is this that original flash meme from way back
in the first couple seasons is going to last to
the heat death of the universe like it's just so
perfect in present day sure is a nice timeline be
ashamed if someone messed it up if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos my post credit scene videos full Easter
egg breakdown videos we'll start posting tomorrow
and Friday all the way through the weekend there's
so much stuff that we have to talk about be sure
to see the movie as quickly as possible but at the
beginning of the new trailer you see a much longer
version of Ben Affleck's Batman at the beginning
of the movie earlier in the movie on his new bad
cycle taking down these criminals in Gotham City
it's meant to be just like another save another
date for Batman doing his thing it's their way
of showing you what's happening after the events
of the Justice League Snyder cut like life has
continued Batman is just still being Batman doing
his thing every day in Gotham the difference with
this scene is that it's actually happening in
the middle of the day because usually when you
see Batman and Gotham City taking down criminals
it's happening in the middle of the night the
version of the bad cycle that they had during
The Flash movie is like a slightly different
upgraded version of an idea that Zack Snyder had
for his bat cycle during Batman v Superman in the
Justice League movie I think they would have
eventually done it during the Justice League
movie but the idea is that Zack Snyder had all
this concept art that they didn't wind up using
during Batman v Superman when they introduced
his version of Batman he has some pretty cool
technology during Batman v Superman but it was
really during Justice League when he was going to
ramp that way up like the new version of the bad
copter here which is basically a jet it was going
to be the same thing with his bat cycle so the
version in the movie here has that double wheel
in front in the wheel and back but the version
of Zack Snyder was going to go with was actually
based on that same jet technology so there were
no wheels it's hovered in the air basically you
can let me know which version you think is cooler
like the jet version of the bat cycle or the more
traditional looking one that they used in the
actual movie he's having a conversation with
the flash about the whole concept of Flashpoint
where he's trying to tell him that the Flash's
parents died in Thomas and Martha went like his
own Batman's parents died in the trauma of what
happened forged them into what they are today it
helped make them better even though the fact that
their parents parents died is a terrible thing
while they're cutting scenes of Flash in his Flash
costume back in his childhood room it seems like
there are a couple different parts of the movie
they added together where the flash is coming
up with the idea to go back in time like if I
could just go back in time I could fix everything
I could save my parents I could save your parents
as he's talking to Batman in a completely
different scene in Ben Affleck's Batman's
trying to tell him hell no don't do that you
could destroy everything because Batman's older
wiser and even though it might not completely seem
like it Batman and the Flash actually have a long
history of working together because they're both
basically crime scene detectives like Batman is
the world's greatest detective in the flash
is a forensic investigator working with the
Central City Police Department so they both kind
of do similar things they actually explored this
during the comic during the button crossover
where they're actually meeting and talking
about detective work together trying to figure
out what's going on with the Watchman button so
Batman is meant to be very intelligent in fact
he is the person who created the Flash's ring
from the comics that's based on the way that it
works in the comics obviously slightly different
origin story made from nanotech in present day as
opposed to nanotech from the future so he also has
a rudimentary understanding of quantum physics and
how time works like what happens when you actually
try to change the timeline the short answer is
that nothing good winds up happening and this
is where we get to the idea of Flashpoint Batman
because they're doing a couple different things
with the concept during the movie in the original
story Flashpoint Batman essentially winds up being
Thomas Wayne who's just dead I watched him die my
God he's the one who died that night in the alley
Bruce died and you lived you're his father you're
Thomas Wayne because in the trailer when he's
talking about saving Batman's parents like I could
save your parents in Crime Alley from dying he
actually does kind of wind up doing that during
the original Flashpoint but not intentionally
when he does wind up changing the timeline it also
affects Batman's origin story and in that version
of events in Crime Alley he winds up being the one
who gets killed by Joe Chill in Thomas and Martha
Wayne wind up Surviving and just like the event
traumatized Batman and drove him to become the
Batman character in the future the cape and cow
a version that happens to Thomas and Martha Wayne
but it's a much darker version Thomas Wayne's
Flashpoint Batman uses guns all the time kills
villains all the time and is way more hardcore
way darker there's been a bunch of concept art
of Jeffrey Dean Morgan obviously because he is
the Thomas Wayne of Ben Affleck's Batman Universe
Lauren Cohan played his mother Martha Wayne during
Batman v Superman there's also been concept art of
the flashpoint version of her character and in
Flashpoint Martha Wayne becomes Flashpoint Joker
which arguably I think is a little bit darker
even though Jeffrey Dean Morgan would be like
the Negan version of Batman to make a Walking Dead
reference the funny connection about that too is
there's been all these Easter eggs for him on the
boys TV show which is kind of like a DC parody
with the Justice League the seven homelander and
concept art of him is the tech Knight character
which is sort of an amalgam version of Batman and
the Iron Man character from the Marvel Universe
he'd be amazing in any of the roles because both
versions of those characters like Flashpoint
Batman as well as the tech Knight character are
just totally messed up very cool in messed up
ways in their own way but in completely different
ways like Flashpoint Batman is definitely dark
just really hardcore but if you think the boys TV
show has gone over the top with how crazy it gets
how crazy some of the things the characters do
are the things that Tech night does in the comics
are Way Beyond that way more messed up within the
context of this movie they're basically giving all
that Jeffrey Dean Morgan Thomas Wayne Flashpoint
Batman story to Michael Keaton's Batman Michael
Keaton is basically the flashpoint Batman but
obviously Completely Different Twist on the
character because it's the normal version of his
Batman just later in his timeline like he's a much
older version of his character from the original
Batman 1989 and Batman Returns movies but this is
one of the ideas why Flashpoint fundamentally is a
big Batman story for different versions of Batman
because both The Flash and Batman lost their
parents in tragic accidents so the idea is they
both have a lot in common also fundamentally they
are both detectives so to speak so there's just a
lot of things in common between the characters
which is why it's weird that you don't see them
working together more in the movies but in all the
Justice League sequels that Zack Snyder a planet
like Justice League 2 Justice League three a lot
of their story is tied up together like the whole
idea with flash time traveling Batman gets into a
lot of that like you see in that distant nightmare
future both of them are working together still
Batman is trying to help Flash and Cyborg try
to figure out time travel so that they can save
this version of reality I'm sure there's going
to be a lot of questions about how time travel
Works inside the DC Universe because obviously
they're using this movie and the whole concept of
Flashpoint to read boot into James Gunn DC chapter
1 Gods and Monsters this was a big thing when
Avengers end game came out and they had the big
time travel Heist because the Marvel people had
their own explanation for how time travel worked
how timelines worked and now that's like a whole
big thing with the Multiverse all the different
timelines in the variants of Kang the interesting
thing they've done in the DC Universe with The
Flash movie is they've actually drawn things
a little bit closer by changing the original
Flashpoint sorry they've changed their explanation
for how time travel works and it's actually a
little bit closer to the way that Marvel explains
time travel now whereas in the original Flashpoint
comic book the explanation for time travel was
much simpler but The Flash movie is actually
going with more of a Marvel explanation where the
flash causes Flashpoint but what he's doing is he
causes a version of hyper time which is a DC
concept where a bunch of different timelines a
bunch of different possibilities start overlapping
with each other all of reality kind of starts to
blend together and get completely messed up so the
whole idea is that he could theoretically destroy
everything in the Multiverse if he continues to
make it worse there will be some Henry Cavill
Superman scenes during this so he's not completely
out of the movie but all the scenes you see with
this version of Supergirl are basically a version
of Flashpoint Superman they're just giving the
story to Supergirl instead their story plays
out pretty much the same way like he winds up
being a much stabbier version of Superman because
the military kept him captive underground for so
long even though it is really cool that Michael
Keaton Batman is coming back as his version for
this movie it would have been cool to see Jeffrey
Dean Morgan as a version of Flashpoint Batman he
said many times that he is totally willing to come
back and they might have actually thought about
it at one point before they got Michael Keaton
on board for this let me know in the comments
if they do wind up doing Jeffrey Dean Morgan as a
version of Flashpoint Batman at some point in the
future how do you want them to do the character
because they did say that they might wind up
doing the flash shoot like a flash sequel movie
just depending on what happens with this movie
even James Gunn was asked at the Guardians of
the Galaxy Premiere what's going to happen with
the future of the flash franchise and he's like
well we're just kind of waiting and seeing seeing
what happens Ben Affleck actually joked recently
on a podcast about how he felt like this version
of Batman that he did in this movie was the best
version ever and how it actually made him want
to come back a little bit like I know I said
I was out and I wasn't doing any more Batman
but I was so perfect in this movie I kind of
want to come back a little bit maybe I wouldn't
hold your breath on him coming back but we might
see him cameo in some future major crossover in
like the next 10 years congratulations T Feist
22 you're the giveaway winner from my last big
Flash video please email me on the about page of
my channel so I can get your contact details so
everyone click here for that full flash movie post
credit scene video I'll update the link as soon as
I post that and click here to watch Batman learn
about Henry cavill's Superman for the first time
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!